como entrenador deportivo tuve mucha
fortuna porque conocí a interesado el
primer equipo que yo dirigí al director
del tecnológico de monterrey en
querétaro que se estaba dedicando al
desarrollo de las habilidades de
pensamiento
yo tenía 40 años y me llamó mucho la
atención ese término y eso qué
como desarrollar inteligencia
inteligencia
yo tenía venía con el background
de que yo como estudiante fui - días
si me explico como estudiante fue unos
días
un cero a la izquierda
me paso por la primaria por la
secundaria y por la presa sueño lágrima
me salva que salvo el deporte de las 8
horas
cuando le pregunté a este hombre y la
inteligencia se puede desarrollar claro
me dijo entonces le hizo una pregunta
como para que no me las respondiera
aunque pasa con los muy inteligentes
y me dio una respuesta a brillo muy
inteligente con respecto a qué
todos los somos inteligentes como todos
tenemos talento
no tenemos inteligencia para todos
porque la inteligencia no es un
componente único son muchas habilidades
sujetas al desarrollo
este hombre se dedicó a hacer un
programa de desarrollo de habilidades
del tercero de kinder hasta último año
de prepa
me involucré habiendo ha sido un
estudiante -10 pero me quiere por tanto
el tema por qué
siempre pensamos que el alumno que saca
9 y 10 en matemática es un gran alumno
los demás y existimos yo nunca llegué a
6 en matemáticas por eso el primer
paradigma que yo empecé a desafiar es
el de la inteligencia que hoy nos
interesa como el talento porque es
nuestra capacidad para dirigir bien el
comportamiento para que quiero yo un
alumno 10
con mérito si no tiene habilidades para
la vida que es lo que nos está pasando
actualmente por eso este taller o este
curso
que estoy dando para adolescentes
si me amas porque no crezco
y no crezco porque es muy fácil
los padres hemos sacado de la educación
del hijo el dolor
no queremos que enfrenten dificultades
problemas y desafíos
entonces cómo crecen
les hacemos a un lado todo lo que puede
hacer sufrimiento
luego lo que tenemos que hacer es
entrenarlos para el mundo real y
enseñarles a sufrir con dignidad
qué es lo que menos estamos haciendo
entonces me involucré mucho con este
hombre con este programa y de haber sido
un estudiante -10 me dediqué a ser
entrenador de maestros para el
desarrollo de habilidades de pensamiento
y encontré mucha influencia en grandes
educadores mundiales que sin duda han
dejado una huella perdurable en mí el
primero que encontré la mejor educación
que he leído sobre educación
pitágoras hace 2500 años la educación
nuestra carrera para vivir sino templar
el alma para la dificultades de la vida
maravilloso
encontré el gran educador humano judío
que hizo el programa 5 pedagógico en
israel después de la segunda guerra
mundial
robbie rogers time
en sentido figurado lo dice no hay que
enseñar idiomas no hay que enseñar
técnicas que se llame todo lo que hay
que enseñarle a la gente es a cambiar y
lo que tenemos que empezar a cambiar es
la inteligencia
y tercero el gran pedagogo el filósofo
español actual
que es el hombre más dedicado al
desarrollo y la educación del talento
jose antonio marina
le preguntaron a marina oiga
defíname con una frase esta época
dice el despilfarro de la inteligencia
a ver explícame cómo es eso y se mire
yo fui profesor de preparatoria y tenía
un alumno brillante el mismo cociente
intelectual que tenía este
pero resulta que a los dos o tres meses
ya no lo vi más
ningún alumno cumplió pero a los tres
meses desapareció y un día me lo
encuentro por la calle
y le digo oye fulano que está qué pasa
contigo que mirar lo que había más dice
es que sabe qué pasa que ni la escuela y
los profesores a mí después de esa
llamada
si se marina al poco tiempo me enteré
que como era líder si yo junto a otra
gente se dedicaron a vender drogas a
hacer pequeños robos es decir
la pregunta si este hombre que tenía un
coste intelectual joven y de 150
el inteligente o era estúpido
por eso nos interesa desafiar otros
paradigmas el talento que esta letra
capacidad por compromiso en el entorno
adecuado y la capacidad tiene dos
dimensiones una aptitud con pe
conocimientos y habilidades
y la otra actitud comportamientos por lo
tanto
talento es de qué manera aportó valor a
lo que yo sé puedo y quiero hacer
talento tenemos todos sin excepción
no tenemos talento para todos por eso
tenemos que buscar como decía la joven
cuáles son fortalezas
normalmente casi todos tenemos 8 o 10
fortaleza
si ustedes se encuentran tres y a las
tres talacha ya le hicieron
pero talacha es decir todos los días
durante diez mil horas de trabajo
deliberado
10.000 horas de práctica deliberada
fácil preferente
se dice página
talento y lo otro porque a través de mi
trabajo por los adolescentes una época
fantástica de la vida aunque todos
tenemos
sería muy negativa sobre la adolescencia
siempre hemos creído pero primero siete
años son los más importantes en la vida
de un niño si son importantes pero
cuidado
hay una segunda época de oro del
aprendizaje que de los 13 en la mujer
hasta los 20 y en el hombre
[Música]
hasta los 24 25 maduración es decir
de los 13 a los 25 tengo que empezar a
tomar la vida en mis manos
quiero no porque no quiero porque en
casa no me permiten enfrentar el dolor
en casa no me permiten que le valga por
mí mismo
[Música]
entonces
cuando trabajo o cuando interactúa con
niños con jóvenes y con profesionales
pero sobre todo con niños y con jóvenes
que hacen algún deporte les sugiero que
para hacer un mejor deportista en cuanto
a rendimiento necesitan primero trabajar
sus hábitos personales y porque sus
hábitos personales porque es a través
del hábito que se forma lo que hoy
necesitan los jóvenes urgentemente la
formación del carácter
carácter es manera de pensar sentir y
actuar adquiridas nadie nace con
carácter el carácter se forma y de qué
manera estamos insistiendo con los niños
y con los jóvenes que formen su carácter
que hagan todo lo que pueden hacer por
sí mismos por ejemplo el niño desde los
2 años de edad puede después que termina
de jugar juntar sus juguetes el
colocador con la ayuda de mama o de papá
en el walt que le corresponde a los 3
años junto a los juguetes y ponen el mal
delito para comer
a los cuatro juntas juguetes por el
mantel hito y después que termina de
comer poner en el fregadero y al niño le
encanta hacer todo eso
pero aquí a los 10 años no he hecho nada
de esto si le digo que ponga el plato en
el fregadero me manda
qué desperdicio que estamos haciendo por
los jóvenes
los estamos capturando los estamos
utilizando
por eso sugiero desde los 10 años el
niño tiene que levantarse solo
cuando les pregunto a ellos no sólo que
te levantas mamá se tiende a la cama no
la atiende te haces tú lo que no me dan
dinero contratando más cuatro de las
torsiones
y 55 entrenó entre los más recientes
le preguntas a mamá a todos los días
mamá es que la puedo ayudar
por eso si me amas porque no creo
no crezco porque no estás utilizando
no crezco porque las cosas que yo puedo
hacer por mí mismo las estás haciendo tú
el desarrollo de las habilidades de
pensamiento e inteligencia desarrollar
el talento que todos tenemos y ver de
qué manera a través de los hábitos de
vida formó el carácter
porque las otras tres aspectos que
tenemos que desarrollar
luego no son
como voy a manejar mis emociones sobre
todo el niño y joven que hago cuando
estoy enojado contras y triste con este
preocupado
como se comunicó conmigo mismo
como me comunico con los demás
2 de qué manera aprendo de decirme a mí
mismo liderazgo personal que el
liderazgo es de qué manera influimos que
si solamente los demás pero parecido a
los demás primero me tengo que cuyo
y tres más el carácter fundamental hoy
en día el desarrollo de carácter
cuando estaban construyendo la capital
la catedral de chartres pasó y turistas
con los canteros que estaban picando
piedras y me preguntó hoy lo que está
haciendo
no se da cuenta que te pica en tu piedra
fue con el segundo y le dijo oiga usted
que está haciendo estoy haciendo un muro
y fue con un tercero y el tercero le
pregunto qué está haciendo estoy
haciendo una calle llegando a hacer una
catedral
ustedes
van a seguir picando piedra van a hacer
un muro
o van a construir con su vida una
cátedra
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]